aquí nos dan una función htx y nos
preguntan cuál es el intervalo de h que
tiene una tasa de cambio promedio
positiva así que como siempre pagos el
vídeo y primero inténtalo antes de que
lo hagamos juntos ok vamos a trabajarlos
juntos para empezar recordemos qué
significa tener una tasa de cambio
promedio
puedes verlo como el cambio en el valor
de tu función con respecto a un cambio
dado en la variable de entrada un cambio
en x y podemos ver esto como primero si
quieres saber nuestro denominador este
será el intervalo que elegimos que es la
diferencia de x final menos equis
inicial y en el numerador tendremos el
valor de nuestra función en la equis
final menos el valor de nuestra función
en la equis inicial ahora nos piden que
calculemos esto para todos los
intervalos para encontrar en donde es
esta tasa positiva
y si observas aquí necesitamos que la
equis final sea mayor que la equis
inicial para que tengas una tasa de
cambio promedio positiva es decir
necesitamos encontrar una hd x final que
sea mayor que hdx inicial si el valor de
la función en el punto final es mayor
que el valor de la función en el punto
inicial entonces tendremos una tasa de
cambio promedio positiva así que veamos
si esto ocurre en algunos de estos
incisos para este punto inicial tengo
que h de cero bueno un 70 será igual a
cero tengo un octavo por 0 - 0 ok y hd 2
es lo mismo que un octavo por 2 elevado
al cubo que eso es 8 entonces un octavo
por 8 es uno menos 4 es lo mismo que
menos 3 y observa esta vez no tenemos la
situación donde h de tu punto final es
mayor que h de tu punto inicial de hecho
tenemos una tasa de cambio promedio
negativa así que cancelar este inciso
para ayudarnos a visualizar este ejemplo
fui a des mosses y atrás de la gráfica
de esta función así que la voy a traer y
puedes ver que tenemos una tasa de
cambio promedio negativa de x igual a 0
a x igualados en x igual a 0
estamos en este punto de aquí en x
igualados estamos aquí y observa esta
función podemos ver que en x igualados
el valor que tiene la función es menor o
también podemos pensar a la tasa de
cambio promedio como la pendiente de la
recta que conecta estos dos puntos y
puedes ver que tenemos una pendiente
negativa es decir una tasa de cambio
promedio negativa entre estos dos puntos
bien ahora que hay del inciso b bueno ya
calculamos que h de cero es igual a cero
y cuál es el valor que tenemos naché de
8 bueno
un octavo por 8 elevado al cubo se elevó
8 elevado al cubo y después lo divido
entre 8 eso es lo mismo que 8 al
cuadrado que es 64 menos 64 entonces
todo esto me dará 0 por lo tanto aquí
tengo una tasa de cambio promedio de
cero porque el numerador será igual a
cero así que en definitiva puedo
cancelar este inciso y podemos verlo
justo aquí cuando x es igual a cero
nuestra función está aquí cuando x es
igual a 8 nuestra función está por acá y
puedes ver que la pendiente de la recta
que une a esos dos puntos es 0 por lo
tanto tienes una tasa de cambio promedio
de 0 entre estos dos puntos ahora que
hay del inciso c bueno h de 6 es igual a
bueno tengo un octavo por 6 elevado al
cubo
veamos 36 por 6 es 180 más 36 que es 216
y esto menos 36
ahora un octavo por 216 esto es lo mismo
que bueno 216 6 por 6 por 6 es decir
tengo 6 por 36 y bueno seis octavos de
36 eso se simplifica en tres cuartos de
36 entonces tengo tres cuartos de 36
menos 36 lo cual es menos 9 si quieres
puedes sacar la calculadora o puedes ser
una división larga pero espero que hayas
entendido estas cuentas que hice fue
sólo un poco de aritmética entonces hd 6
es igual a menos 9 y hd 8 ya vimos que
es igual a cero así que el valor que
tiene mi función en este punto final es
mayor que el valor que tiene mi función
en el punto inicial por lo tanto en este
intervalo tenemos una tasa de cambio
promedio positiva
así que seleccionaré esta opción también
podemos verlo en x igual a 6
nuestra función toma el valor de menos 9
justo aquí y cuando x es igual a 8
nuestra función
por lo tanto puedes observar que la
recta que conecta estos dos puntos en
definitiva tiene una pendiente positiva
tenemos una tasa de cambio promedio
positiva bueno si estuvieras haciendo
esto por tu cuenta y hambre has
terminado pero debemos revisar también
el último inciso si comparamos h de 0
que sabemos que 0 con h de 6 que sabemos
que es menos 9 puedes ver que tenemos
una tasa de cambio promedio negativa
porque tenemos un valor menor en el
punto final de nuestro intervalo así que
cancelaría también esta opción y puedes
verlo por aquí si observamos los puntos
que se forman en x igual a 0 tienen que
es igual a 6 podemos ver que la
pendiente de la recta que une esos dos
puntos es negativa por lo tanto tenemos
una tasa de cambio promedio negativa
justo en ese intervalo